and we want nothing to do with that
we also grew up in the same household dynamics
why can't you do it all
same dynamic
same shared experiences
we have completely different perceptions
why can't you
on their physical health
it's because men like and grew up watching their moms do it all
and so there lies attention
except we are traumatized
and so they look at us and they're like
watching their moms cook clean
although we grew up in the same households
that's their expectation
my mom did right
so I was talking to a friend recently about gender roles
and women have very different ideas
black brown Arab communities
do all the housework and then also work full time right
is like if their mom did it
and why it feels that these days men
at the same time
of what the gender roles look like in a marriage
and she brought up such an interesting point
we saw the toll took on their bodies
and she said that the tension
right and we were specifically talking about Muslim
on their mental health
watching our moms do it all